so I hi I'm Pete and since me I do many
things I like to walk I like to hike I
like the climb but also I am a data
scientist anyway so I guess it's a
little bit unusual for a data scientist
to talk about they do engineering
projects so I always deliver whose first
data hire about a year ago as I came
into the project came into the company
there was lifting nothing so in while
the title is very much about Luigi this
is very much the story of how kind of I
came in from square one and put some
that together so yeah I work for
delivery and fleurs you've not heard was
before we're a london-based
tech startup and we do delivery this is
primarily for restaurants so how about
the restaurants that normally wouldn't
do delivery we provide a delivery
service with an app and a website all
this kind of things now I submitted this
talk a couple of months ago and as I
kept finding it around to starting to
write it about Wednesday night I I kind
of decided them the title was quite dry
and quite hard to get started so I've
actually come up with a different title
so I do apologize but I'm changing the
title to this why it's better to be
woken up by your cat than by the server
alarm so what do I mean by that so this
is my cat kitty so a Shibboleth kitty
this is kitty lovely little creature
kitty is very particular in her ways so
kitty likes to have breakfast 6:00 a.m.
sharp and she does not get it kitty has
no respect she is she's in your face she
wants a food at 6 o'clock
where's my breakfast this for those
people come across it it's page of Duty
page your duty is an application now
it's very widely used by many
engineering people to tell them when
things break and it has much much less
for your personal space they've respect
your personal space so first you not
bad-mouthing pager duty but basically
you can connect up your servers when the
alarm goes off it phones your phone it
sends you an email since your text the
light on your phone flashes and
basically all hell breaks loose can you
fix it so let's compare the two so beta
G so go anytime it's a nightmare right
this thing likes to go off at 3:00 a.m.
Sunday morning after a big sullen area
out awful right it's like the loud
ringing and it's like and if you don't
answer the phone it phones your boss and
all these kind of horrible things and
when something goes wrong it can take
hours to fix right you're dealing with
some kind of problem on the server
you've got to diagnose it you're fixing
and Apache gonna ship the patch kit to
you on the other hand right kitty only
goes off once a day and it's very
predictable 6:00 a.m. set your alarm for
five to six and you're always good it's
a very nice kind of cute patting motion
to get in your face waking you up and
usually it's solvable simply by opening
some cat food so in summary I think we
can all agree with my premise kitty is a
lot better than pager duty
so that's kind of the the the how I
wanted to feel about this and says it's
putting the motive topic it's been quite
a long year but cut to the chase let's
get to it let's start at the beginning
so chapter 1 the model so I first joined
delivery this is kind of like summer
last year cut into summer last year and
the first thing and we decide to do
let's build a model write some of the
scientist building bonds is what I do
right we want to build the model to make
our systems better cool so I'm a
plaything guy been doing that about 10
years now so about six years I've been
dated by 10 so first thing I do is wait
cool I'll open if I open Python file are
like okay let's import pandas that's
like you know get ready to plant
database get the data in get in a data
frame I can start modeling but where's
the data right so in the room we have
when I when I joined it was still a kind
of a rails monolith right so we have a
thick application layer in rails and
then a single post production database
supporting everything else so how do I
get that data hey man just just PD dump
the dick the pod database that's going
to be totally fine I can spot the data
engineers in the room from that noise
this is kind of my reactions but I know
enough about these things no that's
that's bad idea right especially to try
and do that with any kind of repetition
that's bad right
so I knew enough to say actually let's
try and do this a bit more sensibly
right so I spun up a read slave so this
is suppose you use postgrads you can
have like a secondary kind of streamed
version that you can just read data from
without actually hitting the production
database so we can set that up easy all
the data from that database to somewhere
I can work with it's like a warehouse
and I got and then from there I can
actually start to train some looks so I
can actually start to do some science
right so I would a load data I want to
do some transformations and I want to
actually then do some modern top of it
now in the beginning kind of thing that
was cron right you set up cron and you
do a job something happens and it's done
the problem is if you've got two jobs or
three jobs or four jobs how do you know
the first job's finished before the
second job before the third job before
the fourth job and so how do we know how
do we ensure those tasks can run in
order because if they don't things
so exactly this so this is this is I'd
like to infuse this idea of kind of
flowcharts and everyone here has been to
kind of junior school so I'm sure this
is very familiar idea but what we're
saying is I want one two and three two
one four four four I want four to run
before five six and seven
and I went five six and seven to the one
before eight and I don't want anything
to propagate until all the things before
we're finished right I'm basically
creating dependencies for kind of my
tasks the fancy word for this is a
directed a silica graph which means it's
like a network shape directed means it
goes in a direction along that network
so the links have direction and it's a
silica so it can't move back on itself
so I will now refer to these as DAGs and
and apparenty this is really funny I
don't know the test group loved this so
I'm not talking about dogs I'm talking
about DAGs okay so how do we do this
enter stage left Luigi
so as marco la puerta earlier I'm
mocking you intimate Marco wait for me
if you hear no okay cool all this stuff
was wrong my stuff right if he any
questions fine so it's a library that
Spotify put together about two three
years ago I think and they were very
interested in batch compute mainly on
Hadoop hashing they're doing a lot of
MapReduce type stuff but really kind of
we saw this and thought actually we're
not doing MapReduce we weren't working
with particularly big data we're talking
kind of tens of millions of rows nothing
more than that
so actually we want something just to
manage the dependencies but this looked
kind of like a cool way to do it here's
some syntax for though I'll kind of do
this briefly cuz I know some of you
sauce already but effectively what we do
is you import Luigi you extend the the
past class and then you define three
methods so requires so you actually bake
your dependencies into your tasks right
so this is one pass and I say this task
before it can happen this other some
other task has to have happened first
right and then do the meet so I go right
I'm going to run some stuff so I'm gonna
you know I'm gonna take some kind of
class that I've created I'm gonna stand
she ate it do some stuff and then write
some output in this case I'm basically
writing log files right and then finally
I say my output this is where the log
file is and this is really important
with Luigi because the existence of this
log file with the parameter stamps and
this contents tells the next task gets
finished
that's how the next one knows this is
done so that's Super Bowl
Luigi also provides a number of other
really cool tasks which I immediately
jumped on because I want to move stuff
from one database to another so they
have this thing put the Luigi postcards
copy to table which is an even simpler
type of Luigi task right and in fact you
only need two methods in this class you
the requires again so what tasks do I
depend on in order to be able to do this
stuff and then you need to met the cool
rows so you just you just overwrite
overriding a method from the base class
and it has to return a couple of tuples
but as long as you return the top of
tuples it's cool right it can run
whatever you like in here it brings
about the top of tuples and it will try
and load it into your database using the
in PE class parameters you specify right
so you give it your host you use all
this kind of good stuff
and then you define the schema for the
table the table doesn't exist it will
create it if it does it'll start it cool
so that's how kind of Luigi basically
works and we can then string these
together to create our that so for
example I want to load two tables but
only one load kind of new stuff from a
sun-like row count or something so I can
check the maximum ID I want to do make
sure I have that information ready to go
and it's it's off to date I then load my
data and then it's a right I need both
these pits of data to have loaded and
then I can do some kind of modification
may be an aggregation maybe your roll-up
and then I can make my mom went so in
summary dads solve that dependency
problem it's a solved problem and I love
this last year but it's great and it's
solved it's lovely so write this code
I'm so nice Luigi it's all written just
in vanilla Python and actually 2.7 I'm
really sorry it's not fighting three but
if he was here he'd shout at me but it's
fine and make this fly we'd bang it on
ec2 right so really really stupid simple
we have a production database I've read
only slave which is the replica I talked
about where you have a
Luigi pipeline running on ec2 that's
pulling from the read slave dumping into
an Alex database and then surfacing that
to services effectively so I've got
sequel access to the database I can use
my side compte to library and python to
actually read stuff and do stuff with it
and I can you get to do something called
periscope which is our bi tool which
going to be basis pipe and sequel it
gives you chance so to make it work now
I've got all a machine it's not enough
just to write the tasks I need to tell
the Ouija to actually do so I do this by
first DIY an entry point so effectively
when you run Luigi you only hand it one
task right you say do this task
and it will then take that task and then
effectively all
look through the entire kind of
namespace find all the tasks that it
depends on and their dependencies and
their dependencies construct that
bagging memory and execute it so
basically I just create this one task
using the wrapper task method which is
the simplest of the lot it doesn't run
anything it doesn't output anything all
it does is say do these requires tasks
so it's a very nice way of putting an
entry point and then I run edge Allah so
Luigi as well as being a Python library
comes with a kind of a binary that will
effectively run Luigi services for you
and make sure things are running in
parallel and you launch it really simply
so just one Luigi D in the background
set where you're on the pit file to be
and the log directory and then it's off
so that gives us me now of a scheduler
we have code base that subscribes our
bag and we have effectively classes that
say what we want to actually do inside
each of those tasks final thing we do is
actually kick this thing off so quick
shell script helps us out here so okay
so just getting the weight directory
clone the repository down and then
basically fire so you just blind - and
then whatever python file you have your
entry point in as long as it's able to
import all the other tasks they can be
kind of impacted beneath it you should
give the name of the task you want to
run and until how many workers you want
to execute with so spin up this many
Python processes and then attempt to run
things in parallel you can go really
crazy high with this um basically having
more workers than you have CPUs seems
not to be a very good idea anyway
so we help this shell script and then
finish all off we've got a simple on tab
line so at 4:31 a.m. please execute this
shell script and drop any errors out to
this log file easy and we're done so
what this was what really drew me to
Luigi and why are you kind of stuck with
it for as long as we have in because we
were able to get started in hours right
this was kind of like my second day I
was getting data into a warehouse and I
could build ones fantastic so there we
go got to the point now we can actually
start to do date science
to uq options so all looking great have
my data I'm doing my job a few weeks
later something happened I had to Google
this
so it turns out database to change right
I get to kind of knew this right um so
obviously at the time and even today
delivery was still quite a young company
we're actually still making a lot of
changes to our platform adding a lot of
features which means that the schema of
the underlying databases changes
frequently pretty much daily right at
this point
so the um gonna have this interesting
conversation with the kind of a head of
engineering about this saying we're not
prepared to give up the right to change
right being agile is important to us and
we're going to continue to change and
it's your job to deal with it thanks Bo
all right so the schema can change at
any time without warning so how do we
deal with this right as a data scientist
who set up a pipeline that I don't wanna
think about I join it to work late so
okay so straight up pad to schema
changed there's a table in the database
that says has a rails migration been
applied today look at that table
no migrations been applied just add the
rows what rows are new from yesterday
add them to Davis this schema has
changed
drop cascades schema on the whole
database drop everything remember the
we're talking come out you know tens and
millions of areas kind of thing we can
load this stuff in about three minutes
so drop the whole thing we load at the
tables easy all right
I can't put it quite as well as this so
I'll let Ripley take it
this kind of affectionately this became
known as the new Kajal in that when
things change we just nuke the database
and start again yeah as many data people
in the background oh yeah anyway so what
this allowed us to do this meant we can
handle schema changes right this this
simple pipeline that's there to
provision for a data scientist it's
working its happy I'm cool we decided to
add some tests I decided to add some
testing in because hey testing is cool
how do I do that
so actually what I did was I used there
something called Luigi parameters but
it's allowed us to say let's create
operating modes for Luigi so I actually
ended up adding two operating modes a
test mode which effectively says for
when I'm running the pipeline run the
pipeline exactly as it is but onto a
different box don't write to the same
database right deal with a different
database a different schema and that way
you can actually replicate the entire
thing but you're kind of fine we also
said I also put in their unit mode so
this is saying if I yes all of my tasks
are running quite well contained in unit
testing code but how do I check a task
in its independence that it's going to
run how can I have debug tasks like that
so I added a unit mode which basically
said don't use the requirements and you
can configure all these using a really
really cool thing called Luigi parameter
so Luigi tasks have a signature based on
the parameters that you passed him and
so you parse Luigi tasks a an instance
of a Luigi parameter and that signature
then defines the item potency of that
task has this task run right so you'll
say this task has a date this task has a
table name that is doing it has a an
infrastructure which were working on and
you say right is it a test mode if it's
test mode change all of the output where
you're pointing the outputs and if it's
a unit mode just one the task you've
been asked to run this meant that we now
have like you know a relatively testable
pipeline which is great because it means
that now nothing will ever go wrong ever
again I think some of you can kind of
see what the next bits gonna be about
but anyway so make your testing
competitive right it's super important
it's so easy not to do this at the
beginning but you just end up coming and
having to do it later it's also really
important to make your testing fast so
while we're testing a whole pipeline
here you can find there some bits where
you can use mocking and like um in kind
of fake data sets that will like
effectively not be as perfect a test of
the whole pipeline but they will at
least tell you if they're kind of the
source data hasn't changed will it go
work okay fine at this point I started
getting interested in other data that
liver has so we have a production
database with Khan who would walk where
were the drivers all this kind of stuff
but we actually use a number of external
services so I want to kind of get my
hand in some of this one external
service of use is called stop Matic and
staff Matic is a festive scheduling tool
and we use this to schedule our drivers
right so who's going to work when and
where so effectively I built the class
up that allowed me to fetch the data
from that that data source while also
taking care of things like dealing with
duplicates because in this particular
data source it doesn't have the idea of
rows you're getting objects since you
need to deacon of DG based on unique
identifiers so we have this class and
then we can just instantiate this class
back into our death rows I talked about
in terms of the post press the post
brace tasks so instantiate my class tell
it all the things I'm interested so
which part of the world don't want to
load stuff or don't wanna is it a test
run
which table am I going to write to and
I'm gonna say write build the shifts and
then get the shifts and that's going to
return back to me
a couple of couples that's in the
correct format alone at the day base I
plan that in so again just a slight
change on earlier I've now got kind of
my stuff medic my driver shadowing
system I was putting in Google Analytics
data and this is deer who's come on the
website how many sessions how many
conversions that kind of stuff as well
as some met office data so I was really
interested in this is data point which
is where you get UK weather data it's
awesome anyone's not used that they
actually categorical they rather than
just giving you a humidity and pressure
and stuff they they've done loads of
work coming out what a good categories
of data so they say they have like a
category for like kind of slightly
overcast and that actually means
something very scientific and is very
well defined in terms of how the data
clusters so what have we learned here
keep Death Row's super short first time
I wrote Death Row's it was like kind of
80 lines of code you can't you know test
that awful don't do it right separate
classes test them is unit tests and then
important class and just use that
something I wish I'd known when I
started this I think I thought of beacon
system in the design of those loading
classes right so anyone who uses
scikit-learn you know that all the
models have a train function a fit
function that will have a predict
function I didn't really think of that
up one so I ended up with a couple
classes that had like one is get rose
what is get shift what is get actually
if you can come up with a simple design
pattern beacon system that'll also make
life easier and you should also expect
these external API stew misbehave oh
actually that's not quite true you
should trust them as if they want to
happen and anyone who's played with the
Google Analytics API will know that um
sometimes there are server errors on the
other end who knows why it's mystical
dimensions appear and disappear it's
just how it is right anyway whoo cool
right I'm two months in at livery
I've got a database I've got my core
data I've got my external day so it's
relative liable and tested everything's
great I'm happy as a lamb and I'm doing
data science cool right so all of our
data is now in one place and remember
this is a startup right I'm the first
day to go so for the first time ever we
have a lot of data in one place and all
these Ops guys whoa awesome can we can
we get some reports off that you know
just just kind of like a nice - hair
I've got super critical budgets do that
that'd be awesome
yeah um so this happened those who don't
follow the kind of the startup
investment perhaps and we kind of got
some money which we basically used to go
say we kind of open we started out just
London now kind of like all over the
place I'm sure many of you are annoyed
by how many riders get in your way on
the roads so suddenly I ad hoc database
that was built kind of a single-use kind
of like you know low reliability but
kind of it's good enough for what I was
doing
suddenly we've kind of ended up in this
world where we've accrued tons of
technical debt like almost overnight we
have all of our core actually got
business critical apps being used kind
of potentially around the world relying
on this kind of relatively flaky thing
and then this happens yeah I kind of my
report needs to be ready at 10:00 a.m. 7
days a week and if it's not numb an
unhappy cat this is kind of definitely
one of my bigger learnings is that it's
very easy to kind of do something that
seems very simple at the time you know
kind of oh we've got it let's just put
the reports that'd be great and then it
kind of comes to bite you in the ass
later so kind of stuff that was
happening so people saying right so the
reports not really why is the report
already oh because and then you say
something that might as well be in that
in and they go I don't care I want to
report so job is very much white why are
these things failing actually start from
the beginning why thinks failing go
backwards and fixed off so firstly what
we're having was upstream I'll explain
all these in a second but we're having
problems upstream so if a task upstream
falls over that I don't care about it
can still stop things I do care about
happening I can also have stuff failing
that I kind of care about but I don't
care about much and then finally I can
have just straight-up data that's very
flaky so in terms of these upstream
failures let's think about this kind of
simple bag so I've got my start I load a
bunch of stuff my I finished my load and
make a bunch of stuff and I finish now
this design paradigm for building dams
was kind of it felt very intuitive and
kind of elegant which is why I did it so
the idea of okay load all the stuff
confirm everything's loaded make loads
of stuff so it's kind of like going out
come back in go out come back in so
you've got these connect chat points it
felt really really kind of simple in my
way of doing it the problem was that
this kind of thing would happen so loads
one and two would work with load and
that will be cool but load three fail
and because the load three fails load
Dom says they're not on me
so actually I'm gonna stop I'm not gonna
proceed I'm gonna say enough and that
means none of these folks happen either
so what's happening is this might so say
this is the management report and this
is the data I need for the management
report but the management reports not
happening even though the stuff that I
need is kind of done so this means my
Daggers program so yeah so exactly this
right so this one doesn't need look no
need load three so we changed the DAC so
we remove the dependency to make one on
to load all and just load just change
the shape of the dag this now means that
when load three fails boom awesome I
have basically managed to segregate out
parts of my dad such that the things I
really care about I've been very very
clear these are the minimum things that
need to happen to make that happen I
made it just depend on that and what
we've done here is we've decided
basically we're making the students
about what can be what do we not mind
failing that much and what things we
really care about we've done that by
isolating the clinical opposite jobs
awesome what do I saw what next come on
brain yes and this happened so hello
kitty again so for anyone who's used
Luigi this is the kind of a very flushed
out version of the Luigi give me screen
I just go a lot faster so what happened
here was that we were loading currency
data and the currency data had to be
able to go fail to load that day now if
you're building a financial report for
investors that matters at home right if
you're building a daily ops report it's
like you okay so it's out by like a kind
of a tiny fraction I don't it doesn't
make any difference right so when you
think about it in its code its simplest
form I'm dropping a table creating a
table and doing some data and started to
think which of these things can go wrong
and the answer is that all of them can
go wrong you might have a transact
transaction lock on the table you might
have some kind of like mr. configuration
in your data structure that means you
can't create it you might be trying to
load the wrong kind of data or the
schema just any kind of thing now so
actually when we designed this it was
also cut it was all thinking about the
whole when you're writing code you try
and keep your method small right small
testable simple apply the same thing to
my dad I'm gonna have a lot of very
small very simple tasks and actually
this is a bad idea because you cannot
persist
transactions across tasks right so I'm
doing database work here
I want to say right I want to create my
table a create a new table load some
data into it get rid of the old table by
renaming it and swap my new table into
its place if I do all of this as a
single task I can run this as a single
database transaction which means that
actually I can then roll the whole thing
back if it goes wrong so for those tasks
where failing once or twice in a row I
don't mind so much I can actually do
this and get away with it yeah and then
I started to read about defensive
programming anyway
Google is my friend so yeah encapsulate
logic and bigger chunks cool okay so
this is not quite how it went down but
kind of to give you a flavor so I
started getting a lot of messages like
this the reports broken dude fix it fix
it and I'm the alarm hasn't gone off
there's nothing in the log files it
looks you know everything the code ran
and it's fine yeah apparently we of the
people that came to our website 230%
bought something but it worked we do a
lot of monitoring we use some cool dated
open monitoring which is awesome but you
know we actually we were looking at
things like what's the database load or
we wanna go to memory that kind of stuff
we actually we decided we needed to go
beyond that and actually measure
outcomes so actually we started doing
these new tasks we're actually using
effective which one to do here is we're
creating integrity tests on the data
itself effectively data quality checks
right and then we're building metrics
and then posting those metrics to our
monitoring service I metrics a really
stupid simple right like how many how
many rows are there in the tables that
kind of stuff they've got a bit more
complicated over time but even just
doing this we can actually start say
like kind of the mark I was talking
about earlier this number should be
between this number and this number well
with this we can actually start to have
real-time monitoring of so this is the
difference in terms of the number of
rows in our orders table between our
warehouse and the production system so
as you can see over the course of the
day people buy stuff and I'm only
loading once a day so the diff increases
and then drop back down when I load an
actual you can see sometimes it goes
crazy and we can actually set thresholds
on this plug this into our letting
systems so if it's a it's more than
2,000 rows out I get a message on slack
it's more than 4,000 rows out page Duty
goes off we can you actually stick these
into a slack Channel and this has been
this is where you helped us kind of keep
on top of this and share the kind of
workload so monitoring and letting on
outcomes as well as system metrics and
yeah and you slack
final chapter I'm gonna make it I'm just
turning to make this so we've went
global somebody made heard let me start
it out we were just kind of UK and life
was easy right so we would start selling
stuff at midday and we'd stop taking
words at 11 o'clock which meant I got
downtime I got loads and loads of
downtime to do stuff we then started
doing kind of more countries in Europe
so flights in Germany and some others
but you know it's only an hour so
shifted so generally you've got loads of
time then you're bringing Dubai and
Melbourne and Sydney and suddenly
there's no such thing as downtime
anymore suddenly we need to be very
resilient and we need to have not not
have big overnight batch jobs that take
kind of too much time so what we were
doing before was we had our nuclear
option right if things change drop the
drop the whole scheme oh and we load it
so the obvious thing to do here is to
stop doing that so instead what we do is
we hash the table schema nice thing
about PO squares you can like weed that
table schema hash it and then say right
has it changed into the last hash if yes
drop that table no mean that table for
everything else just leave them so
actually what you vote from schema
monitoring basically to table monitoring
and this allowed us to get rid of the
nuclear option sorry roughly cool I was
going to kind of waffle here but I've
got like three minutes left so I'm just
going to rush through this so this is
kind of from when I submitted the talk
to now we've learnt some more stuff so
I'm just kind of really weekly go over
that when it comes to BI old school will
still apply if you want to build like
kind of you know matrix style data
reporting for your company off databases
star schemas whole app cubes classical
bi type techniques are still really
really good right data marts all of this
kind of stuff yes I know there are
people having some success running these
kind of systems off things like in
parlour but for us really this kind of
methodology is still like is the gold
standard for doing this in figuration
the management is also which moves
towards docker - yes this is steins
better we'd already this just means that
you have a lot more control of how
things are configured and how you deploy
things and how you have a liability and
if things go wrong you just kill the
task and start again
disputed workers we were running
everything on a massive each ec2 machine
this didn't scale so we've actually
implemented something called salary
which is like a distributed working
worker system that's kind of backed by
rabbitmq so actually now we kind of have
the ability to effectively scale our
compute
horizontally we're not doing like kind
of you know we're not trying to sort
terabytes of data or anything like that
but we should have thousands and
thousands of jobs happening and finally
we're moving away from talking to day
basis and towards talking pretty much
exclusively over our message bus on
rabbit and we're looking into
implementing proto three at the moment
which is the Google standard for
effectively kind of three a schema data
that you can move around on your cue so
at the end of the content final thoughts
I think it's been a good year I've
learned a lot and it's been a very
educational yeah I'll give it that and I
think I'm really pleased that we tackled
this problem the way we did rather than
you know rather than kind of going oh
let's just buy an off-the-shelf solution
from somebody or just kind of like
trying you know use a service that will
do all of this kind of stuff for us by
doing this we welcome control of
everything and we could actually make
actually improve over time and like
bring all of it together in Python
everything's defined in code I guess not
many people in this room have I used to
work for a big consulting company and we
dealt with a lot of kind of like very
traditional kind of ETL type systems or
you kind of you know have like a GUI and
like we configuration files and stuff
like that with with Luigi everything is
code everything is unit testable
everything's in github everything
deploys from Travis super handy and you
get all the benefits of those tools I
manage do all of this with like two
people so myself and my colleague Bertie
all he's looking at his phone anybody
and we owe this and we did we did it
with a tiny budget right this is all on
a double us with like kind of an ECG
machine you know RDS database so it was
quick it was cheaper than it was loving
and this is this if you take one thing
away from today like this kind of region
Eric from from this presentation it's
this all the time you spend thinking
about the build process like how do you
make it fast how to make you liable how
to make it deployable
it's like the best investment of my time
I've ever made so that's even if it can
be difficult to get your boss to
understand why do you need to spend
three weeks working on some engineering
stuff I don't understand rather than
building the report that I need super
super important do this and think about
what those dependencies actually mean
so in those DAGs that I showed you you
have about two boxes with a line between
them what does that line actually mean
is that like a solid line is that a
dotted line does that mean have to does
it mean usually it means sometimes so
that that that interrelationship between
the the tasking of dag is super
important so just finish
some slight different so so at livery
obviously we've ranged in food and we
actually deliver a lot Fernando's and
some of you may have happened remember
this happened on the internet awhile ago
there was this whole thing on the
internet about people Americans couldn't
understand what we meant by a cheeky
nandos right yeah it kind of went on on
this was huge in our office and I think
it's very hard to explain so I was gonna
explain with a really really simple
example and that example is this to come
to a PI data conference like this which
is kind of very much you know not for
most of all quite serious for a
technical and to really blatantly do a
hiring slide at the end so yeah so we're
looking for data engine is in Python if
you're that kind of person that's kind
of work and come grab me and Bertil
afterwards I'm also I'm the lunch today
if you didn't like that tomorrow we do
deliver you can get five pounds off with
this code to stay in and yeah and I'll
stop now so see Bob thank you so yeah so
that if if the policy is to drop the
database schema when everyone's when we
want to reload data and the scheme has
changed and then we know the entire
thing what happens to people that
reading that database um yeah they get a
connection termination and and actually
you have to connect them because
otherwise you can't drop the schema
folks guys won't let you but we got away
with it because we're doing it for him
in the morning
and that's why outside yeah so so yes so
saying now we're 24 hours is that a
problem which is why we've kind of done
this so we now look at the scheme of an
individual table and in what we do is in
a single transaction we try and we
basically create a new table load the
data and then flip them around at the
end of the transaction so it's only
transactions that span the entire so
other transaction that might span that
period of time they would then feed it
but that's actually very rare in our
system I do I have to pick a gentleman
would bid so so given what I know now
would I still do the same thing again
yeah absolutely so I think in terms of
the spectrum of tools you can choose to
do this the really nice thing about
Luigi is it's really super simple right
the syntax is very simplistic everything
comes as one piece you do it on one
package you can deploy it so simply it's
literally you can just like take take
that code but don't get half put it on
the server and rhythm on it I think
there are definitely better tools in the
open-source space for kind of more
comprehensive stuff so you've heard
about airflow there's things like ASCAP
an Azkaban and Uzi then you've got the
Corp space you've gotten thematic and
stuff like that but we wanted we want to
cheat we want it quick and it's perfect
guy in the back and holding town at the
whole time yeah yeah so we at the time
when we were doing that we load
everything from source right simply
because this wasn't really data
warehousing project it kind of became
one by accident at the time I just
needed access to the data to build
models and like loading at the time when
we started was kind of after 30 minutes
yeah which is why we have to drop it and
we load the whole thing from source yeah
but this is not this is not the
production database this is not the
production baseball fall over this is
not the production based production
database backups this is entirely
independent system pick okay the song
really excited generally the bosses oh
right so the question is the tool I was
using to do our data kind of colatina
integrity tests yeah we just wrote that
but it's not a complicated thing it's
it's running sequel rush using pandas to
run sequel storing it's a data frame and
then posting that over HTTP to dates dog
and it just thought it basically it just
deals with storage of the metrics
tracking them over time alerting all
that's the forest
yeah so this the question is how do you
profile the pipeline right how do you
check what's taking time what's taking
longer and longer and meta debt in two
ways and so we also have a task has
started postal poster a notification so
we store those kind of accidentally so
it's task has started task is finished
so we can track all of that but Luigi
also comes with a last time I checked
still prototype history database that
lets you go in there and say what time
did the top you know and it gives you
that for each task you can say where all
the historic when it ran when did it
start when it finished so you can you
can kind of work back to that so the so
the question is does the Luigi history
tell you which version of the task and
and the answer is no so what we do is we
we just cross correlate between the task
database and the github history so we
can just look at the commits how much
time loads sweet can do all of these
right FARC only been looking for a
tune-up what's up
so the question is around the fact that
you know I've built the database for one
purpose and then it became effectively
the BI sauce for the company I think
didn't do what do I convey it was a bad
idea and what are we doing the future
with that so I think was it bad I didn't
know absolutely absolutely not I think
in terms of the kind of the business
value that the company got out of that I
think in some respects those reports
were probably worth more because before
that it was you know it was it was
actually I think when I when I first
joined if the CEO wanted to know how the
company performed the previous day the
CTO wrote a sequel script an executed
you know that was that was actually what
was going on so I think we had a huge
amount of value and freed up a lot of
people's time I think and that kind of
about this whole kind of agile process I
think in the long term the architecture
sucks as we scale and actually what we
have done that I haven't thought about
is that we've actually I moved to a
redshift warehouse that basically
supports all that kind of BI stuff and
we're looking to put the potentially
some martin and we're doing kind of the
more real-time applications that are
gonna be running off the mapping queue
system anymore
no luigi is very even ill about this it
ran away didn't the dependencies are
very fixed so the way we actually deal
with this is try accept within the past
themselves so what we actually do is say
try this log if it didn't happen
sometimes we do try it if didn't work
try it again certain map times and if it
doesn't work log that it didn't work and
count and start to count how many times
it hadn't worked and then alert and so
it's likely if it fails once and put
message in slack if it fails five times
in a row sound the alarm
now airflow does that though
ah yes so the question is why are we why
have we gone down the salary road from
when Luigi potentially could do that for
us and how I forgot with that so does
Luigi do distributed work sort of I mean
if you look if you actually look into
how kind of Luigi as ions and again data
scientist talking datum engineering here
as I understand what it's doing is it's
Luigi is not a distributed computer
system it is a it builds bags and tells
an execute attacks what you do within
the tasks is entirely up to you so the s
there are some past templates for
calling out to MapReduce which i think
is mostly how Spotify use it we don't
use MapReduce so that's not made a lot
of value to us
so actually what happened is most of our
compute sits on the ec2 node in the same
machine as Luigi it's spinning up other
processors but it's all the same machine
so by going to the reason where we
actually here I say put it in it's kind
of it still on test our celery
deployment and it's on ECS at the moment
and it seems to be running okay but the
beauty of that is you get kind of a very
true scalability and what we're actually
doing at the moment of kind of fess up
to this is we are now trying airflows
because that has a lot more
out-of-the-box support for that and it
will give us the ability to auto scale
the cluster on AWS so that we can then
start to say things like this job must
finish by 9:30 if it doesn't auto scale
that we can make it faster gentlemen
so so other question was Luigi's design
for batch processing which is use it for
kind of more real-time or near real-time
applications no not even close mate stay
a million miles away for that if you
want if you want to do because because
it because of the color that the dag
kind of concept it's you're basically
baking a lot of requirements into these
things and it's it's you you end up
doing a lot of hacks to try and kind of
like the thing I talked about snowed
like try/except and all this kind of
stuff to try and get it to fly if you
want to make things going real time
there are much better options for that
kind of thing so message queues for
example on one of those so the question
is we want our primary ETL one today do
we ever respond to specific events so we
actually run once a day once now and
watch every 15 minutes now that's
because we're running the live report of
it which I'm hoping to stop doing as
soon as possible in terms of reaction to
events you could do that we don't what
we have looked at recently is AWS lambda
as a way of doing that kind of thing but
we haven't found any any use cases where
the kind of things we're doing would be
reactive enough and actually those kind
of real-time applications 10 what tends
to happens we build them into the real
stack that stuff cool anymore one last
question and was only it's two hands up
you had a question man you had a
question
jumper the back
so the question is because we've baked
this agility into the development
process and allowing us to change
schemas consistently has that created a
lot of problems and kind of effectively
cost well as we scale in terms of our
kind of data warehousing and so forth
the answer is I think like many such
systems is that at the beginning hell
yes all the time as the code base has
matured we found in fixed bugs the
ability to deal with those schema
changes has become very robust the
problems we tend to be coming across now
are more that we've now built something
else on top of our kind of data pipeline
and that and now suddenly there's
something else to change and the one
thing that you can't really protect
against is if someone removes a piece of
business logic so if someone decides to
take out the column that says this is
how much the order cost all the reports
that say how much we charge people are
going to stop working right and there's
simply no way to do that and to be
honest when and if that does happen I
take a lot of comfort from the fact that
the alarm will go off because that is a
problem so I think that's it thank you
much for coming